la señora Hilda mamá de Jorge Antonio
está aquí en esta marcha señora qué le
diría usted a las autoridades en este
día
de ellos saber realmente lo que pasó la
verdad no queremos otra narrativa y que
esas personas que atentaron contra los
43 jóvenes Pues que reciban un castigo y
que no se sigan incurriendo a personas
que participaron en la desaparición de
ellos Muchas gracias el caso se ha
complicado con la filtración del
expediente del nuevo informe del caso
Ayotzinapa el presidente López Obrador
dice que sus adversarios no quieren que
se llega a la justicia que quisieran que
su gobierno fallara en el compromiso de
llegar a la justicia y llegar a la
verdad Pero que no va a parar y que va a
llegar hasta el fondo lo mismo sostiene
el presidente de la comisión de
Ayotzinapa dice que seguirán recabando
información pero los padres los
familiares los amigos de los jóvenes
desaparecidos ven lentitud en las
pesquisas y exigen justicia como lo
hacen
26 de septiembre
[Aplausos]